the Pentagon is considering sending
10,000 troops to the Middle East is that
purely a defensive move or something
more it's it's purely defensive if we
end up doing that we don't have any
announcements but we always look at our
force posture in light of threats that
we're receiving and starting on May 3rd
we started really receiving a variety of
threat streams that suggested that Iran
was planning imminent attacks against
American interests in the Middle in the
region and so we changed our force
posture to be one in a defensive
position so that if we're attacked first
we can defend ourselves do you have any
evidence yet of what Donald Trump said
at the weekend that Iran quote wants to
fight yes we have multiple threat
intelligence reporting that Iran was
planning kinetic attacks against
American interests and it was over many
days very credible and sustained
intelligence reporting detecting plots
to attack American interests in the
region and so we very quickly
repositioned military assets to defend
ourselves and we think that was the
right decision the Iranian ambassador to
the UK told Sky News don't test ear on
we are prepared for all eventualities
what's your response to that we're not
testing Iran Iran has been threatening
to attack American interests that's what
our intelligence clearly shows and so if
Iran does attack first the United States
and an act of self-defense will defend
itself and we will respond with military
force but we are in a responsive
reactive mode the administration says
that it doesn't want to go to war but
are we getting closer to that only if
Iran brings us there everything the
United States has done has been
defensive and our foreign policy
continues to be consistently diplomatic
you're increasingly prepared for the
prospects if Iran is going to increase
its threat level against us it would be
negligent if we didn't posture ourselves
defense
Tivoli would it not be easier to
confront Iran's malign behavior whilst
reducing its nuclear program you can't
do that outside of the deal can you
well Cornelia you can you are able to
being outside of the deal gives us
enormous freedom to go to deter Iran
when we were in the deal all of our oil
sanctions and our banking sanctions we
couldn't touch because they were
suspended during the life of the deal if
they don't have that revenue they can't
fund Hezbollah and Hamas and Palestinian
Islamic Jihad and the Houthis in Yemen
and their Hsieh proxies in Iraq and
Syria that's what's going to determine
there have been reports of splits within
the administration on what to do with
Iran how joined up is the thinking there
is a unity of purpose to take a
different approach to Iran ultimately
the president decides and we have had
nothing but full agreement on what we
should be doing to deter Iran from
running an expansionist foreign policy
from trying to acquire a nuclear weapon
and from sort of its regional aggression
because this is the president who
campaigned on a platform that he did not
want to get involved in Foreign Wars he
does not want to get involved in Foreign
Wars but he will take action when
necessary to protect American interests
as he did in Syria